>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
DONALD TRUMP RAN ON THE PROMISE
HE WILL SECURE OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WHEN HE RAN IN 2016.
HE RAN ON OBAMACARE AND ENDING
THE IRAN DEAL.
BUT IMMIGRATION RESONATED.
NO OTHER CANDIDATE SAID ANYTHING
LIKE IT AND THE VOTERS LOVED AND
SHOUTED BUILD THAT WALL.
ENTIRE POPULATIONS FROM LATIN
AMERICAN ARE MOVING NORTH.
IN FEBRUARY AUTHORITIES
APPREHENDED 76,000 ARRIVALS AND
LAST MONTH THAT BALLOONED TO
100,000.
THEY COME BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
CAN COME.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM CAN'T STOP
THEM.
IF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS SHOW UP
HERE WITH CHILDREN, THEY WILL
NEVER BE DEPORTED.
CLOSE TO 100% OF FAMILIES THAT
CAME ACROSS THE BORDER LAST YEAR
ARE STILL HERE.
THEY KNOW THE SCRIPT.
EVEN CNN CAN'T LIE ABOUT IT
ANYMORE.
YESTERDAY, TO HIS CREDIT, ONE OF
THEIR ANCHORS WENT TO THE BORDER
AND TALKED TO PEOPLE TRYING TO
CROSS ILLEGALLY INTO THE U.S.
WATCH THIS CONVERSATION.
THE MOST HONEST THING THAT HAS
RUN ON CNN A LONG TIME.
>> WHY DID HE TAKE HIS KID HERE
WITH HIM IF IT'S JUST TO WORK.
>> [SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE].
>> HE SAID IF HE COMES HERE WITH
HIS SON, HE IS ALLOWED TO STAY.
HE THINKS HE IS ALLOWED TO STAY.
>> [SPEAKING SPANISH].
EK
>> THIS IS WORD OF MOUTH.
IF YOU BRING YOUR KID, YOU CAN
GET IN?
>> Tucker: OUR CURRENT POLITICAL
CLASS HAS PRETENDED THIS IS NOT
TRUE.
IN CENTRAL AMERICA THEY KNOW
IT'S TRUE.
COME TO AMERICA AND BRING YOUR
KIDS.
FREE HEALTHCARE AND SCHOOL.
IF YOU LIVED IN HONDURAS YOU
WOULD COME HERE TOO.
THEY KNOW WE ARE HAPPY TO GIVE
OUR COUNTRY AWAY.
LAWMAKERS ARE ALLOWING THIS TO
HAPPEN.
THEY COULD CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES
IN AN HOUR AND LIKELY WON'T DO
IT.
THE INVASION'S EFFECT ON NORMAL
AMERICANS AND THE FENTANYL
CRISIS THEY DON'T CARE.
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE TELLS US
EVERYTHING IS FINE.
DEMOCRATS REJOICE IN THE SCALE
OF THIS DISASTER.
MORE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION MEANS
MORE POWER FOR THEM.
EVERYONE RUNNING FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINATION AGREES ON
THIS.
>> WOULD YOU TAKE THE WALL DOWN
NOW HERE?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> OFFER A HOME TO REFUGEES.
THAT'S OUR VALUES.
THAT'S PART WHAT HAVE WE DO.
>> INSTEAD OF BUILDING A WALL OR
CLOSING THE BORDER, WE SHOULD
CHOOSE COMPASSION INSTEAD OF
CRUELTY.
>> WE WELCOME REFUGEES AND BRING
PEOPLE OUT OF THE SHADOWS.
>> SPENDING 5.7-BILLION DOLLARS
ON A WALL IS NOT AN EFFECTIVE
USE OF TAX DOLLARS.
>> WHEN WE TALK ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY.
THERE ARE BETTER WAYS TO DO IT.
>> IMMIGRATION IS NOT A SECURITY
ISSUE.
IT'S AN ECONOMIC AND
HUMANITARIAN AND FAMILY ISSUE.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING AS AN
ILLEGAL HUMAN.
>> Tucker: SAID THE SITTING
UNITED STATES SENATOR.
SO CONGRESS IS NOT GOING TO FIX
THIS.